[Music]
Hey good afternoon thanks for coming I'm
Aaron Subramanian I lead the data
science and analytics team at Baker
Hughes G company will talk today about
how we deal with analytics at scale for
the industrial world specifically for
oil and gas but in more in general what
are the scalable aspects and what are
the commonalities of analytics in the
industrial world right and just to give
you a little bit of an introduction of
the kinds of problems that we're
interested in and by we I mean the
larger GE so this is the largest G
company so for those of you don't know
every two seconds then airplane takes
off somewhere in the world with a G
engine on it about 30% of the world's
power is generated by a GE turbine of
one kind or the other right and we
formed make a huge G company last July
by merging G oil and gas with Baker
Hughes two companies which by their own
merits we're a large chance in their own
merits but the merger brought together
the first world's first full stream oil
and gas company by that we mean the
first company in the world that can do
exploration for oil extract oil ship the
oil refine it and then do something with
the refined products right so make
energy you make something else with the
products the only company the first
company in the world that can do that at
scale now to do any of these individual
things by itself is a big feat doing all
of these things simultaneously in one
company requires us to build a lot of
models repeatedly and I've not even
touched upon what we do in the
healthcare space or in the
transportation space for example these
are just simple examples and to do this
at scale daily we have to build
thousands of models and for us models
are any representations that connect a
set of inputs to a set of outputs now
that can be as simple as a simple
equation or a full-blown partial
differential equation that takes about
two months to solve on the world's
fastest super
computer right all of those things for
us is the model now to do this
effectively we of course need the raw
material for it which is data and we
deal with data in two ways so we have
what we call two big dichotomies of
silos the first silo is data the second
silo is analytics or second silo is
subject matter expertise I'll first
tackle the data silos and if you look at
across the entire industrial spectrum
the first one of course is oil and gas
here listed from there to aviation they
take an aircraft that takes off from New
York lands in London the actress was
designed about 20 years ago the engines
are not collecting that much data that's
roughly about a terabyte of data
generated right not much of it is stored
not much of it is analyzed but today's
newest aircraft generate about a
terabyte per hour of flight right take
that in the oil and gas world where an
offshore oil rig for the past 30 years
has been generating roughly fifteen to
twenty thousand tags for the data every
two seconds and almost all of it has
been stored compared to the power or
transportation or the aviation industry
the oil and gas industry has at least a
couple of orders of magnitude more in
terms of data primarily because they had
to deal with uncertainty from the get-go
there's very little you know about the
reservoir there's very little you can
actually model or control about what
happens subsurface but as an engine it's
complex it's extraordinarily
sophisticated but you control almost
everything around that particular field
so then certainties exist but they're
far smaller right so the datasets that
you see in the oil and gas world
significantly outstrip anything else in
the industrial world but if you compare
that to any data sets in the ERP systems
tradition of the ERP world for the last
20 years the last 30 years where you
think about any transactional data sets
any kind of maintenance records any kind
of information that you've been sharing
and storing and retrieving in the
traditional enterprise world dwarf gets
dwarfed by the industrial data set by at
least two to five orders of magnitude
both in terms of volumes and
but and there are no systems that have
been developed that would tackle
something at that scale even the modern
industrial the Internet to dot all kind
of technologies where we track
everything that everybody is doing in
this room everybody that's doing
anywhere in the world where they are
where they're going what they're
probably going to do it still gets
dwarfed significantly and I'll give you
some examples of how we go about solving
it but this is just one side of the
story right the data silo is one side of
the story that everybody talks about the
other side of the story is the analytic
silo
or the subject matter expert silos where
people have been building analytics for
decades people have been building
analytics for 50 years what if we have
the luxury of going and building a model
from scratch from a data set that you
still have to prepare painstakingly
that's a great thing you have a lot of
frameworks out there today to go build
but if you had models that have been in
production for decades that people
understood have been using it in
production today folks were using it may
not necessarily understand all the
nuances of the model you don't
necessarily want to go touch it you
don't necessarily want to go tweak it or
change it you want to be careful about
the same thing in the financial world
where you really don't want to go change
the financial metrics without
understanding what went on for 20 years
internally right very very similar
things here the only difference is the
consequences of doing something wrong
can be catastrophic imagine we have to
decide based on a models prediction
whether I have to shut down an offshore
oil rig which is producing about two
million barrels a day I have to predict
whether a particular engine or a
particular aircraft needs to be pulled
for maintenance this take before this
take off or is it okay to leave the
airport today quite consequences of a
wrong decision are catastrophic and
false negatives are really not okay so
there are no models that we generally
tend to build where false negatives are
okay and false positive rate so that's
why generally high roughly around twenty
to thirty percent would be okay for a
model in the industrial world but a
false negative rate meaning
the risk of me saying something is okay
when it's really not okay has to be zero
or as close to zero as possible right
that's where the consequences come in
and analytic silos exist because of that
because it takes a lot of expertise for
somebody to build and maintain these
models now for us to come in and scale
this if I have to democratize analytics
for 5000 engineers in a company like
Baker Hughes for example I can't
necessarily go in and say it drop
everything you're doing here is the
brand new framework go build all your
model to the brand new framework some
would but most of them would still go
back to Excel spreadsheets and in some
cases their Fortran code but that's what
works and they know it works right so we
need to somehow bridge these silos
together both the data silos and
analytic silos and fundamentally getting
a federated orchestration engine where
you have a lot of these models talking
to each other not necessarily
independent islands but actually models
that talk to each other is fundamental
if you want to scale analytics in the
industrial world and I'll show you some
examples of that but example that you
see here where there is a Python model
that gives an output that gets fed into
a Fortran 77 model which we can only
probably run as a black box that then
talks to a model that's written and go
that then talks with model that's
written and see it's a daily reality for
us it's not a nice italic example in
fact there are very very few examples
where we had to build a model that gets
you to an outcome that's just written in
one framework
okay now I've listed some of these
things some of these things could be
provocative some of these things you
could say myths or reality depending on
your point of view and what your
experiences have been but we've heard
all of these things and we talked to
customers on a daily basis and
irrespective of where they are in their
journey for digitalization where they
are in their journey from moving to the
cloud or not whether they believe in AI
or whether they think it's a myth a lot
of these things are what customers tell
us daily now there is some truth to a
lot of these statements but they hide
the bigger truth right so for example
one of the one of my favorites is when
people say neural networks are all new
the general statement is I've done this
in the 90s when I was doing my Master's
they're really bad they got to about 60%
accuracy they really never got anything
meaningful and engineering partland so
we moved on what's so new about all
these new neural networks are coming up
and the other thing I didn't list here
was people telling oh I've done deep
learning 20 years ago and for those of
you do deep learning here you know
that's really a silly statement and but
the reason why people walk around with
these myths is because they haven't
gotten the outcomes that everybody seems
to be promising with analytics and by
the way the analytics promise has been
the same for the last 25 years there
used to be the digital well of the
future and that actually came out and
late 80s and early 90s where they wanted
to go censored up the entire oil field
and say this is going to create a huge
revolution that's like me coming and
telling you email is going to make you
more productive so it's it's just has to
be balanced with what and how you're
actually applying things to and just to
bring home the point I want to walk you
through a few examples and they're one
of the favorite things and just a full
disclosure right so my background is
through-and-through aerospace
engineering I grew up in the physics
world we did data science as a necessity
we got into doing large-scale data
science because physics alone was not
sufficient but the general pushback from
most subject matter experts is the world
has been run from by physics we
understand it that's the only thing that
can solve all kinds of complicated
problems right so if you were to predict
purely from data where a particular
stone would land if you throw it and you
don't know anything about gravity the
only thing you need to go by is
observations of each of the stones that
are being thrown if you have to only
purely build that model this is how it
looks like
so the projectile is going we don't know
anything more than saying it's a
selenium projection if there's the first
time I'm observing it takes me more than
10,000 observations to track that the
stone is even going to come down I don't
know anything about gravity right and
even the simplest model the most
sophisticated model you can build
requires a lot of observations on the
flip side if you're a high school
student and you're given the same
problem
see he stopped working you know he will
tell me that all the data you need is
just one data point all you need is the
velocity the speed and the angle at
which you threw the stone at anywhere in
the universe where there is gravity
you can predict precisely where the
stone Atlanta right even middle school
physics will tell you that the problem
really is reality if I didn't know
exactly what angle I threw this doughnut
I just add a 1% uncertainty in the
initial angle my output changes were
about 20% if I add a 5 percent
uncertainty in wind speed all of a
sudden you have 100% uncertainty in
where the stone will land and this is
the simplest physics problem you can
tackle it's just one variable and just
very very little uncertainties imagine
if you have to go predict whether a
particular engine is going to have a
fault or I have to shut down an offshore
oil rig massive problem thousands of
variables lots of uncertainties lots of
things you don't know you still have to
make a decision so physics alone can get
us astray significantly in fact in this
problem if we add a few more
uncertainties it'll tell you to the
stone is flying backwards so here to be
very careful with that and the other
thing that people generally don't like
to talk about is the fact that yes data
is cool it's everywhere everybody likes
to use it but the reality is not much of
it is useful so this is a real use case
where the data set is from an actual
assets think of this is a very large
scale asset it could be a jet engine it
could be a gas turbine it could be any
of those kinds of things we are the
equipment manufacturer we meaning GE and
B a GE we have all of the data sets
about how it was operated so the top
left gives you the operating condition
one of the variables that are being
measured for the entirety of this
particular assets life the actual data
there is in blue dots everything else
there is what we estimated or generated
through other sources the reason we had
to do that was because here in our
databases systems of record it says
there's a
started operating in 2001 like that's
their operating condition but that's it
actually started operating in 1994 and
there's lots of things that happened to
it before our systems of record actually
caught up and if I had to go predict
anything about the system and I say I
only go by the blue dots it doesn't
matter how sophisticated my techniques
are how sophisticated my data scientists
are or even the physics based modelers
are the models would still be wrong
because data is only about 60 percent
correct right so we had to go collect
for it and while we started digging into
this over the last decade or so we
realize it's not just missing data is
all not made equal we actually had to go
invent different ways of categorizing
missing data so you have that's why you
have partially missing one to fully
missing one two three and things like
that and each one has to be estimated
using different techniques so imagine
the data scale we started with that
includes the missing data if we add on
the augmentation activity that goes on
to add the missing data back in that
problem becomes two or three times worse
in terms of volumes because the minute
you go add data in and if I change the
color coding to all be just blue it'll
be very hard for you to tell which was
estimated in which was real right
then you were to figure out which models
would use which valve version of the
data sets that you're using and how do
you keep them all in sync that becomes a
massive problem as well and just to show
you the quality of how well we can
actually estimate the top right figure
blue histogram tells you the actual data
set the mean is around 559 with the
standard deviation of about 33 the
estimated values are very very close
it's why 60 versus 31 so it's very hard
for someone to tell after a while but
the dataset was real or not if you
didn't properly tag them and this
happens regularly right this happens on
a engineers desk but they would have
changed something in the dataset passed
on the data said to somebody else
they built a model that had a
significant consequence and they pass it
on and there's no systems of record for
any of us
and that becomes the actual data of
record as well moving forward so really
quickly industrial analytics for us is a
combination of three things people have
been doing analytics for a long time
combining domain knowledge with standard
software techniques right the new kids
on the block are new way of doing data
science mainly deep learning based data
science and new way of building software
on the cloud micro services self
scalable right the traditional solutions
are a combination of domain knowledge
with software I would say finding very
very hard problems or finding solutions
to hard problems like finding a needle
in a haystack is a combination of modern
data science with modern software
predicting what I'm going to buy before
I actually go and buy it hard problem
predicting how long it'll take me to go
home before I actually tell you when I'm
going to go home again a hard problem in
the large cases it's been solved a lot
of cases it's already happening today
the case in point for industrial
analytics it's really a combination of
all three things because it's not even
finding a needle in a haystack it's
finding a needle in an ocean of data
because most of the times the one thing
that you're trying to go predict you
don't have any data for so if you're
trying to predict for example when would
a bearing fail you would have hundreds
of sensors on a gas turbine but you
don't have a sensor on a bearing that's
about to fail many times the sensors
that you have are all confounded and not
necessarily calibrated in the last
twenty years so how exactly do you make
sense of it to predict something that
you're going to go predict without
understanding the sensors around that
particular piece that's really the
problem that the industrial world faces
and that is not just one e teutonic
problem not just one problem here almost
every problem of value is a combination
of all three things and we got here not
as an epiphany moment where we just sat
there and said this is the hardest
problem we need to solve these are the
problems we have to solve every day
these are the problems our customers
have resolved every day if we could
solve it with traditional techniques we
would if we could solve it just purely
with data science we would because
that's the easiest thing to do there's a
lot of techniques out there there are of
systems out there that let you go do
that
the reason we had to go combine all
three things painstakingly because
that's the only thing that actually gets
us to a solution that's meaningful right
now we talk about digital twins a lot
and the world talks about digital twins
a lot today to the extent that it's
almost an abuse term for us digital
twins are very special we get there
because we can't solve these problems
with any of these individual techniques
by themselves and the way we define it
is it's a digital representation of a
physical system or an asset or a process
that has a few characteristics it has to
be life it has to be continuously
updated and it has to be adaptable and
scalable all at the same time now
imagine I have to do something specific
or I have to make something specific and
scalable at the same time meaning I go
build a model off a particular asset or
a particular system I make it so
specific that it's specific to that
particular system it doesn't scale by
definition so how do you go build
something that's both specific and
scalable even worse
I made it specific okay I can somehow
make it scalable I now have to go make
it adaptable meaning if I go change
something in the physical system I
change a pump out I change a compressor
out I should be able to change only that
portion of my entire digital twin and
make the whole thing work again I don't
have to go back and rebuild the whole
thing alright those are very very hard
things to do and the reason we have to
go do it is because we have to run
digital twins thousands of times a day
for every single implementation we have
out there so it's hundreds of thousands
of digital twins running thousands of
times a day so we can't really run these
at scale if we have to go do these
things manually typically how these
things are done you get a team of six to
ten PhDs with some designers who are
experts in the system let them loose for
about six months
and then they come up with one model
that's specific but non scalable and
order non adaptable and the reason why
we had to go mix all these three things
together so we always start with physics
that's physics space so that we can
actually build on top of it where
physics allows us to do no nodes so if
you know something is going to be a
problem physics will get you to a
precise solution very quickly
probabilistic s-- because that's where
we started with without uncertainties I
really cannot predict the real world
right deep learning allows us to really
sleep reasonably well at night because
it allows us to go and deploy these
systems to watch for things that I know
are going to go wrong but I don't know
what they are so I know something is
going to go wrong that's all I know I
don't know where I don't know when so
those systems allow us to go watch and
adapt the models for that right so I'll
give you a few examples of that right
I'll make it a little concrete for you
for what a digital twin is take if
somebody comes and tells you they have a
digital - enough about and in this
particular case this is a well with an
artificial lift system think of that as
a pump it's an electric submersible pump
that's about two miles deep under the
under the earth when we say it's a
digital - enough well we connect it as a
warm model that's the IPR curve - a pipe
model - a pump model - a tubing model
that finally gets you a pressure
differential at the end and what you're
trying to predict is how do I change the
operating conditions of the pump and the
well to make sure that I produce as much
as possible without damaging anything
but the well as well as the pump and to
do this roughly one digital twin has
about eight models running in sequence
along with an iterative loop internally
so it's not just a linear sequence right
and this we would consider a fairly
moderate level complexity digital - now
the way we use it is an operator would
go in and say okay how do i improve my
production from my set of wells to
answer that question on one well I
typically have to run a digital twin at
least a few thousand times and to get a
plot like this where I have a plot of
power versus total liquid flow from that
particular well by changing all the
parameters all the gray dots each one of
those grey dots is a prediction or an
influence through the digital - at the
best family of solutions are on the blue
dots the problem is today I might be
operating on the black diamond without
knowing what my space looks like I might
just randomly increase power and hit any
one of those red dots on the top where I
increased power meaning I'm spending
more and I'm actually producing less
that happens a lot where intuition
intuitively you can go tweak some things
you really don't know where you are in
your design space in this case it's a
fairly simple problem we're only
changing about six parameters but if
you're an oil field there are a few
hundred wells you're automatically going
into a few thousand parameter
optimization problem very quickly and
that happens that needs to happen a
couple of times a day but today the best
you can do with the tools out there not
just in oil and gas but in aviation in
power and any one of these industries is
to run an optimization like this not
even a global optimizer but a local
optimizer it can take anywhere from 20
minutes to about two hours for an
advanced engineer to go run it right so
we took this as an experiment and about
summer of last year we went and built
the digital twin for a single bomb he
took about three minutes for a while we
scaled it with the techniques we talked
about up to now combined physics data
science and software scalable on the
cloud and about six months we got a
thousand X improvement going from a
single optimization that took about
three minutes to run to a cluster of
wells where about 20 wells were there in
a cluster you can optimize it in about
30 seconds right the reason why you get
a thousand X improvement is because it's
not a one-shot optimization it's a game
of whack-a-mole
so you go do something else in one well
something else goes wrong in another do
you fix it
go somewhere else change something
something else goes wrong so you do that
iteratively multiple times in fact to
get to that solution you need to run the
model about 20,000 times to get to that
answer that's really where you're
getting the thousand X improvement but
we wanted to push it one level higher
saying okay we keep the models the same
we scale the software we push it to the
cloud
they actually orchestrate all these
models to run on the cloud and see what
actually can be done at a field level
optimization the solution doesn't exist
today and to be honest none of our
customers even asked us for it in fact
when we go and present it the 20 well
optimization the response was this is
great today we do that once every six
months this one might let us do it once
every two weeks and the field level
optimization the response was we really
did not
this is even possible and the response
was actually opposite they came back and
said can you do 5,000 Wells can you do
9000 well simultaneously because the
pace at which this is moving the
six-month deadline was just because we
had our internal conferences we actually
had it scale in about three months what
I'll show you how we walk through that
and in just a year for an engineer to go
from maybe doing a single bill
optimization every six months to doing a
field level optimization a couple of
times a day it's a phenomenal
improvement okay and the the notion of
using deep learning in traditional
industries like oil and gas or aviation
of power but they're very risk-averse
right they don't really want to trust
the model by itself so here's some of
the things that people generally talk
about anomaly detection but the things
that resonate with industrial customers
is people don't really want to go set
rules most of anomaly detection systems
out there want to tell you to come and
say here is my threshold for a set of
variables set my thresholds and after
that I'll go tell you when something is
going to go wrong and this has to be
done a priori before it goes and catches
things so the biggest promise of
automated anomaly detection with deep
learning primarily is you can actually
catch anomalies without necessarily
knowing what these anomalies are
beforehand I don't have to train for
anomalies or another train rules in fact
I don't even need to tell it what are
the sets of inputs I need to be looking
at as long as you have a data stream
coming in and as long as you knew what
the normal state was I can go say what
was abnormal what that was the first
foray for us in 2d planning but from
there we actually went into deploying a
live application for a customer where
the customer was recording about ten
thousand sensors off an offshore oil rig
actually this was done by the customer
actually already pushed the data to
Google Cloud all we had to do was train
with a six months data set they had
which was normal with no abnormalities
and within about a 6-week period from
starting from scratch
going from not knowing what the data is
not even knowing what the asset was to
having an anomaly detection working in
an application roughly took us about six
weeks and this particular application
that you see here this failure mode that
was caught that's shown in the top right
where it's just an anomaly score has a
combination of about 16 different
sensors we called an anomaly then the
next immediate question is okay this is
something going wrong but is this just a
blip or can you tell me what is causing
this problem that's the plot on the
bottom right and I'm not sure if you're
showing it properly here but the colors
actually indicate as a function of time
which variables are actually affecting
the anomaly score so you can actually
start going and figuring out what is
causing the anomaly that's the next step
the step after that is actually figuring
out what is the actual cause what is the
root cause actually right and to do that
you actually train with maintenance logs
along with this time series data sets as
well so this is actually not to encoder
running for instead of about 24
different variables over a period of two
years builds running live on GCP in
about six weeks right
the other kind of systems that are
actually fairly effective for using in
deep learning is image recognition kind
of use cases right so this is a use case
where if you've driven from here to LA
you'd have seen a lot of these pumps
these are called rod lift pumps and the
biggest problem with rod lift firms are
they fail quite often and the failure
modes generally are categorized using
these images which is a plot of the
force versus displacement of the rod
that keeps going in and out right and
depending on how that shape looks that
what an experienced engineer can say
what is the actual failure mode the
problem is to failure modes look more or
less the same right so it depends on who
you ask and when you ask in terms of
finding out what exactly is a failure
mode until you actually have to stop
operations and then pull it back up
right and whereas if you use traditional
techniques to do distance based metrics
to say this is the overall graph tell me
what this new graph looks like and what
is it closest to you get to an accuracy
of about 60% right so we took the latest
just an image object recognition model
augmented its using x for learning with
just the failure mode images that we had
and let it loose so if I run this demo
for you you can see most of the
detections where on the left hand side
is the data set that's coming in for a
particular pump for a particular model
of pump on the right hand side is what
the model is predicting real-time so
this is a deep learning model built and
deployed for inference on in this
particular case the times are actually
running on an edge device with a small
Jetson with the timing that we are
actually running right so you can see
instantly it is catching with under one
second delay what the actual failure
mode is and this model was really not
that optimized yet we just took the
standard model that was published
augmented it with the data sets we had
an accuracy went from about 65 percent
to 93 percent right the data sets were
not even that high so they're only a few
hundred failure modes and if you
optimize the model so you can get up to
about 93 percent to about 97 percent the
last three percent is something that you
have to go collect more data for so
these are some of the examples that we
are building and deploying in the field
both with just traditional deep learning
augmenting with deep learning right the
other kind of deep learning models that
we're building quite effectively are the
knowledge systems and the requests for
this one came from a couple of customers
where the request was we have a lot of
documents that we have generated over
the last 30 to 50 years we have a lot of
training material that we generally use
for our new recruits to be trained on
our operations and to make sure that we
can actually get them up to speed very
quickly with our subject matter experts
what most of the industries are facing
today are a dichotomy from
the first problem is their tribe they're
losing a significant portion of their
experience to workforce in the next five
to ten years but the other side the new
workforce that's coming in are used to
learning and interacting in a very very
different way they don't necessarily
want to sit through three weeks of
training on just going through and doing
one task they want to be able to go and
learn they want to be able to go search
and find information as they need it the
problem is to enable that and to bridge
the gap between people who are retiring
and the people who are coming in you
need a knowledge system that can quickly
learn and adapt right so in this case we
built up the knowledge system so we had
the standard English language NLP models
we took those and we trained those
models to understand technical English
so how do you go interpret
tables how do you go into prayer tables
and figure captions how do you go get a
natural language query to return an
answer that's not a pure retrieval but
actually something that generates text
so we have to go build that and after we
built that we realized that the corpus
of data that we had to go build it had
to be expanded with all the subject
matter expertise we had internally in
Baker Hughes G right so we made an
English language speaking model
understand the technical language based
on all the technical language documents
that are out there in the world then we
made that model into an oil and gas
person actually we made that into a B a
GE person because it understood our
language and we took that model and
tried to play to a customer and realized
it was like be a GE person talking to a
person in BP yourself we can understand
each other but then we don't know our
lingo exactly we have our own acronyms
so we had to go get the documents from
the customers to augment this model as
well so just to get to a system that
understands a natural language query
respond to it in the customers context
to get to for example a cust user input
going in having a spelling correction
that's oil and gas specific and customer
specific and go through and give
recommendations based on what answers
could be given because if we go and ask
a general question you can of course go
to Google or any of the search engines
and then ask a general question you're
gonna get a very very generic answer
what they really want is an answer
that's specific to the person who's
asking the question in the context of
the company that's being asked so to
just get this one simple example working
where somebody went and type tried
typing in gammer all right so if you go
try that in Google today
it'll get connected as grammar or
grammar early or any of the many
english-language connections right what
they actually wanted was a gamma board
or a HT gamma elite that is specific to
that particular customer they also
wanted grammerly and other things but
they would be ranked down much below
what a general-purpose search engine
would give you imagine extending this
out where you just go start entering
natural language queries and a report an
actual full-blown report gets generated
for you to go train yourself for the
query that you entered that's really
where the oil and gas language model is
getting used in fact one of the the
models that we built with which requires
significant compute is the oil and gas
language model and we continue to evolve
that as we speak and we started of
course with English but because we're an
international company and also the
corpus of understanding about any of the
industrial world it's not just in
English we actually are starting to
build translators from English into all
kinds of other languages as well okay
now the other thing we want to talk
about was democratizing analytics right
now we talked about data silos we talked
about analytics or subject matter expert
silos but there's also the other problem
that we constantly come across hey this
is working on my laptop or on my system
I have shipped it to an DevOps or a
cloud rob's or another analytics person
now it's your problem to run it it just
works fine on my system right containers
solve that significantly but we had to
up skill or up level or analytics folks
because they come not just from software
or programming backgrounds but they come
from deep engineering and physics and
domain expertise backgrounds
so we just did a quick check of how long
it took us to on board somebody so
usually based on a person's background
it would take anywhere from a week to a
couple of months to fully on board
somebody to be productive in building
new analytics and pushing it into our
production systems right and that was
before containers before we had CI CD
pipelines both on the cloud on
somebody's laptop there's more or less
mirror at the same way so it's not just
about upscaling it's also down scaling
how do you down scale your overall
system so that somebody can do their
work in their small ecosystem and then
push it back into that overall systems
as well right so we went from somebody
taking anywhere from a week to two
months to a couple of hours and these
were on tested on a variety of people
where you had a lot of expertise with
containers and almost no expertise in
containers in fact we had people who
came in with absolutely no expertise in
containers or programming who still got
up and running in the first day to push
production code right the other one was
we went through painful quarterly
releases it used to be nerve-wracking
sitting right before midnight because we
had already promised our leadership that
we're gonna release today and something
that was working just fine the day
before or even in the morning would
break just ten minutes before production
we've all been there and it was painful
painful quarterly releases - today we
can actually do continuous releases from
a person who's built analytics but does
not necessarily understand the overall
working mechanics of a large-scale
enterprise software system pushing
something making it into production and
actually being ok pushing it into
production right and we can do that in
some specific cases of course I'm not
claiming we do that on all cases but for
the capability for the analytics person
to write code and the same code to be
shipped to production is fundamentally
if we have to scale any of this ok now
I'll quickly run you through a demo the
demo I'm going to run through is trying
to build a few thousand models rather
quickly on DCP and enable this we
almost all of our services using cloud
native Google services and we have an
internal tool that we also used as an
analytics engine for all of our products
for the customers call apply day I we
are running apply day eye on DCP courses
so it's our core running but using the
GCP core services so we are using the
kubernetes engine we're using say all of
the storage services that Google
provides natively including all the
perimeter security TNS cloud dns and
firewall rules and everything ok and
hopefully the demo gods are smiling on
us let's see if this works ok can we
switch ok perfect so what are you gonna
see here you can see we have a
kubernetes engine we have the cluster
running that's fairly large now we also
have both the browser-based interface
that we won't be demoing today for a
citizen data scientists or subject
matter experts to go in and build a lot
of models but we have a CLI that a more
advanced person can go build a lot of
models very very quickly as well so if I
do my CLI on the left-hand side you can
see I can do a lot of things I can run
login run a few models I can I check the
status of the models but we can also do
guided build ok and guided build is
where I don't necessarily know much
about my problem I was given a data set
by somebody I need to go build a lot of
models with the data set I don't
necessarily know what models I need to
build I don't know what techniques are
going to be useful I don't know if there
is a lot of missing data in it I'm not
given much information about the data
set and that's a very standard use case
as well where somebody gets dumped with
the data set and say go do something
with it
right oh there may be an outcome but
they may not say how to get to an
outcome so about 60 to 80 percent of a
subject matter experts time goes into
figuring out what do I do with this data
set right so this is trying to figure
out how do you reduce that 60 to 80
percent of your time to maybe 20 to 30
percent rather than spending 80 percent
of your time just valuing in the dark ok
now we already logged into the CLI
if I go into our actual kubernetes
engine as usual the token has expired
let me make sure I get my token
you
okay so we've extended kubernetes to
have a graph tab that'll tell you what
services you're running how many
replicates you're running what pods are
running what tasks are running and we
had to do this because without this we
really couldn't go in and figure out how
to debug not only how to debug really
what is the scale we are running it the
numbers that come out and you have to go
do looking looking at logs takes
phenomenally longer time then for us to
go look at something like this and get
to an answer quickly now these are all
the services that are running already
these are the core services that you saw
in the architecture diagram where this
is just the applied AI running and
waiting for somebody to issue any
commands and what you see here in this
big flower is all our tasks services so
we have 50 services running waiting for
any of the tasks to come in if I go in
here and say AI guided build and I'm
saying use a local file and saying out
of all the different combinations of
inputs you can use use the top 10 inputs
that the model is automatically
selecting has to be the most important
as a first pass so this file the data
file has thousand variables they're all
correlated with each other that's real
data set and you as the data scientist
of a subject matter expert can go in and
figure out which variables are important
before going and building a model what
I'm asking is go build all possible
models for all possible combinations of
variables selecting the first ten
important variables per model that's
what this command would do hit enter
what it's doing is it's going off in
this particular case it has 200
variables it's running thousand fifty
six total models and you can see it's
pushing off all of those tasks runs to
the kubernetes engine and as soon as the
kubernetes engine gets all of these
tasks launched it'll then send back and
you can see the graph already updating
it's actually faster on the screen here
but each of the color nodes that are
coming up each one of those nodes are
actual models that are getting spun up
and as we're speaking we've already spun
up
693 models and its life updating as we
speak in terms of going off and pushing
it to GK live off of the conference
Wi-Fi here so as we speaking we just
took a dataset push it out without
knowing what is actually in there asking
the system going to figure out how many
models can you build what are the
combination of inputs that will actually
work for each of those models go build
it and come back to me and show me a
result and all this running live on a
system that's live on Google Cloud in
this particular case it's now already
finished building about 730 models right
and the responses that you're getting
back on the screen there are running
live with all of these containers
getting spawned off inside the
kubernetes engine with all of the
connections between the different
services running ok now can we switch
back to the so what just happened here
was this data set we took this data set
with in this case 200 different
variables with a combination of
correlations between them the plot you
see here each color is a correlation
between one variable another variable
right the system went in looked at the
correlations looked at a lot of the
other heuristics in the data set figure
out what models to build in a variety of
different techniques ran the models and
came back with an answer for you right
now to run this the scale of the nodes
that ran live in a few minutes the 50
nodes running 4800 CPUs with about 30
terabytes of RAM yes you just spun it up
for about 5 minutes came back down but
you saved an engineer maybe two weeks
worth of work and they can actually go
do work on what is more meaningful for
them to go ask questions and get answers
from rather than figuring out what is
this data said actually telling them
right and we have a lot of workflows
built in internally for us to go get the
the acceleration of analytics possible
internally as well
now we
than this on not on Wi-Fi but actually
today morning with the proper internet
connection we could run 30,000 models
live loading up the kubernetes cluster
that I just showed you wait about sixty
percent utilization okay and the graph
actually looks like that it's it went
live in about two and a half minutes
spinning out all the thirty thousand
models like the nice thing about this is
not all thirty thousand actually succeed
a lot of times when you try to push
30,000 models through cluster that is of
this size a lot of those things fail
that have to be restarted automatically
and having gke
having the cloud native services it
automatically restart helps us
tremendously as well really not really
worry about the infrastructure at all
in this particular case right so I won't
leave you with two thoughts one is we're
not experimenting here we're not really
saying this is an abstract thought maybe
that'll be available in the future in
five years time or something like that
we're saying industry is using this
today a lot of these applications may
not seem like additional deep learning
applications traditional cloud
applications but a lot of these
applications are moving to the cloud as
we speak today and a lot of industries
are actually embracing it not
necessarily resisting it and challenges
still do exist
but the biggest challenge of course is
accessibility so everybody says they
have a lot of data but when you go in
and say can you give me the datasets
that becomes a six months to a one-year
exercise because internally they have to
go figure out how to go get the data who
has access to these datasets and the
biggest hurdle today really is not even
just to herd the datasets or the talent
it's really the changing the mindsets
where everybody wants to do something
with analytics everybody wants to do
something with cloud everybody
understands that is going to be valuable
to them it's about how they
contextualize that value to their actual
context that's the biggest hurdle today
so I'll leave you with that thanks a lot
thank you thank you
[Music]